the FBI has seized New York city mayor
Eric Adams's phone and iPad amid a
federal corruption investigation so the
allegations here are that mayor Adams's
2021 campaign colluded with the Turks
usually we talk about colluding with the
Russians or colluding with the
ukrainians sometimes colluding with the
Chinese this is a new one apparently
Eric Adams colluded with the Turks all
right add that to the list the
allegation is that he received illegal
campaign donations from the Turkish
government and what are those donations
according to the New York Post campaign
records show that mayor Adams accepted
$6,000 from three donors who served on a
board backed by the son of the Turkish
president
erdogan seriously